you know the fact is when i heard that
you are now singing it really reflects
that anything is possible and you can
live your passion and i know you've sung
some of the bollywood songs in the past
but this is your first time your
material in english has this sunk in
that you are now an official singer
well it's still sinking in but the fact
that i sung it i mean at some point i
thought i can do this
it's been an exciting journey and um you
know i'm an artist and
dancing and acting and singing is part
of my my personality and my career um
in my home i have a lot of musical
influence because my mom is a classical
singer hindustani classical and we were
exposed to so much music
because of our singing and because of my
dance
i classically trained
dancers so there's a lot of music in the
house and i think i grew up um singing
and you know through school i used to
sing with my mom
and so singing was always a part of me
which was not explored
and i thought you know maybe it's time
that i explore that because i guess you
know in your life you should live all
your dreams you should it was one of my
dreams and i thought that what better
way to express yourself
than you know to write your own songs
and you know sing them
and that's such a beautiful thing right
there that's so influential and
inspirational so to so many women out
there you know never give up keep going
and the fact that you yeah and the fact
that you were exposed to music uh when
you were young from your mom from your
school your brother sent you country
music
how would you describe your music
i think my music comes from the heart
and um i have sung six songs in
different genres like the latest one tu
hamera
on the pop edm you know style
and it was something i wanted to do for
my fans my career spans like 35 plus
years yeah and
you know all the support that i received
from my fans and all the love that i've
received all these years uh made me feel
that i wanted to give back something
and so this song was created it's it's
part of a whole album called the film
star yeah and this is the second song
the first one was candle which i had
released during
the the lockdown in 2020
and dedicated it to the frontline
workers because um
all these songs are like backstories or
about being a film star because
so many things that you really cannot
express
uh you know in words or say that um you
know this is what i'm going through or
uh you know i find it hard and so
when candle was released i think it was
made as a song
which depicts uh the fact that as a film
star there could be a lot of turmoil in
your life on your own life
but you have to still shine like a
beacon of light for everyone you know
you have to inspire them because
everybody looks up to you and you have
to you know live up to that
and so i thought that during lockdown
the doctors and the nurses and the front
line workers
they were the beacon of lights for
everyone and there was darkness
everywhere you know so um so i dedicated
the song candle to them and
the the song um era was about fans now
that's also a part of being a film star
because you know what are you without
your fans yes
i wanted to dedicate a song to them and
it's like a love letter from me to them
if you can you know if i can say that
yeah you could see that in the video too
i mean there's even a dance to it like
am i doing this right is it like this
yeah it's too heavy it's just the
fingers like oh just one finger it's
like your mind do admit it i like it i
like it
well let's go back to your song candle
because again you did that during long
time when everyone was going through
something mentally or you know it was
hard on so many people and there you are
releasing a song trending on tick tock
uh and it was your first english song
i mean what made you say this is the
time
were you nervous what was that feeling
for you to put yourself out there
yeah i mean um
for me it was like we called it the
candle of hope because everything around
us there was so much despair and there
was so much
um
you know distress everywhere that i felt
that you know they needed that hope that
candle that that would just say that
there's a light at the end of this
tunnel and of course whenever you do
something new and you put yourself out
there you are kind of stealing yourself
and saying hey you're bracing yourself
that you know you're going to get all
kinds of reactions yeah but i was very
pleasantly surprised when my fans loved
it and even other people you know the
kind of reactions i got the kind of
response i got from people was very very
positive and you know they loved the
fact that i had you know dedicated it to
the uh and it was during lockdown so we
had
no one stepping into the house it was my
husband who did everything behind the
scenes so he said he went
yeah he went to the university of google
and uh youtube and you know we try to
find out i mean i'm from the industry
but um lighting is something that you
know you have to actually do it to learn
and so we had to find out how to light
up for that particular room because it
was all done inside the house so i knew
how to set up the shots but the lighting
and everything had to be worked out and
he was a cameraman and i was the
choreographer if i if i missed so and
you know facing the cameras and trying
to say okay this shot will be from here
it'll cut here we'll do this we'll do
that so i think we also discovered a lot
about ourselves
yeah learned something new you know
while doing that mm-hmm and to him
i mean how has the response been from
the fans like you said you created for
your fans but what has been the feeling
of the song have they been contacting
you dming you like what is that feeling
for them oh yes i got so much feedback
and even when i go out uh like just day
before i had gone uh for a little do for
my kids school and all the parents were
there and they were like oh that song is
so good and we loved it
you know and it's in english i mean
india is basically uh you know hindi
speaking predominant
but it's in english and that that's
something that people didn't expect from
me because i've always sang in hindi on
screen yeah
not necessarily in my voice there are
few songs i've sung but mostly in hindi
and so for them it was like oh my god
she's singing in english and um you know
that that was a surprise but they have
uh loved it and they said it's very you
know
things are very positive and uh that's
what i like
and i'm really
that happy yeah why did you decide to
make music in english
well because you know i was educated in
english and so
when i think i think when i to write
specially um i think in english first
and so i thought
it's not that i won't write in hindi or
i won't sing in hindi uh maybe one day
but
but i thought the first one that i you
know come out with should be
uh something i'm comfortable in
something that comes from my heart also
i used to sing a lot in english
in school and you know college and
everything
so i thought maybe it would be in my
comfort zone and uh you know um
that's why it's in it's english
do your kids know who you are like do
they know you're the mother exit of the
world like the queen the icon like
has had they comprehended that
well not till they were like six and
eight when they moved to india
but not because they are 17 and 19 of
course they know who i am yeah
uh but you know we are we are kind of
chilled out people i mean it's not a big
deal for us in the house
for them i'm just their mom you know
doing
uh you know being there for them and
yeah so i think um and we do a lot of
stuff together even my kids are great
musicians my are they
yes the older one is um you know a
natural and he plays the piano and the
tabla and
the drums the guitar and he loves music
and and even though
he loves drums so i think we can form a
little band here because even my husband
kind of plays the guitar no way yeah
so we do a lot of jamming sessions and
you know you can see the youtube i put
up with some of them oh i love that and
so first of all what did your mom think
of the song like her opinion matters the
most to all of us so what does she think
it would be absolutely you know that was
one opinion i was dreading
because uh you know because she is
herself um in that realm of music
she loved it she said it's so emotional
it's very nice what you said through
your song
and you reached out to your fans and you
have thanked them which is you know
gratitude and you know she says above
all i mean that's very important in life
what's the advice she gave you to
continue living your passion and living
your dreams
you know she's always been a very strong
support for me in my throughout my life
and my parents have always kind of
encouraged us to do whatever we wanted
in life and she said you know dream
of doing whatever but do it well do it
with sincerity
uh do it with all your heart and um you
know uh be
uh perseverance is a big factor and be a
hard-working person always and and
that's what i've already followed and
that's the path i took i love that and
you know apparently i don't think a lot
of people know that some of the songs in
your indian cinema your films you
actually do sing like it's not just dub
but like i think you sang a song in
devdas right
you know classical dancing and it has a
lilting kind of a beat and um it's uh
it's it was called
shade
so and the bit of the bit i had sung for
the for the song
i have to ask you about that dance
sequence it's one of my favorites you
and ashwari arai i mean you gotta tell
me that is one of you yes was that one
of your favorite moments in in cinema
yes because that song uh not just the
choreography but the way it was shot
like the camera is in continuous
movement it's never stopping for
anything it's like
and uh saroji and sanjaya bansali i
think they've excelled i don't think any
song can measure up to the way it has
been shot
luckily for us sarosh khan was an
assistant on a song called
um
from jewel thief it was called um
and
she was there when that song was
picturized and central bansali wanted to
do something similar with wells trolleys
and shorts yeah people like the
choreography where one character comes
in the other goes out and it has to be
like a cinematic uh you know excellence
and we are lucky that she was
um you know assistant director
choreographer yeah
in that song so she was able to
translate
um dolare dola into something that was
magnificent you know
and of course aishwarya and me
you know dancing to it and both of us
enjoyed uh you know uh doing that song
because uh we have a great rapport and
um so it was just
beautiful while shooting it and of
course after when we shot whether he saw
the song it was just um incredible it's
iconic